les Tortues Ninja sont en fait originaires
des bandes dessinées Eastman et Laird en tant que
justiciers très hardcore et j'ai donc pensé que l'
opportunité ici que je n'avais pas vraiment
vue dans les films précédents était de les rendre
encore plus durs à cuire que je ne les avais vus
auparavant
mec en réinventant le  tortues cette
fois si nous les rendions un peu plus grandes
que nature un peu plus sombres dans leur
conception, elles pourraient être amusantes et dures à
la fois me permettent d'être le dur
à cuire pour une fois
et donc c'était en quelque sorte l'inspiration pour
aller de l'avant et ça se sentait juste  différent
dans le bon sens et se sentait comme un
ajout digne du canon, allez,
vous savez que j'ai grandi avec les tortues ninja
et ce qui est si génial, c'est qu'avec la technologie d'aujourd'hui,
nous avons pu mettre à jour les
tortues et leur donner une portée
qu'ils ont  jamais eu auparavant nous aussi
et avons pensé à quel point il
était important pour ce film d'être le
film de personnage et à quel point la performance
est importante, nous sommes donc pendant environ six sept mois, nous avons
pris chacune des scènes et pensé
à propos de vous savez comment rendre cela
possible sur le plateau,
je pense que le précédent dans la séquence est
vraiment très important pour le type de
film d'effets visuels que nous réalisons
souvent, vous devez prévisualiser une scène
pour savoir exactement quoi  tirer et
vous ne perdez pas beaucoup de temps sur le plateau,
certains des précédents se
déroulent depuis des années, je ne fais que planifier et
proposer des plans de tournage et des trucs
comme ça, donc ça fait partie intégrante
et c'est aussi très utile  planifier
le tournage,
voir Jonathan est vraiment doué pour
jeter un coup d'œil à ces scènes et placer des
caméras fonctionnait et
expérimentait un peu certaines des
choses changent à ce moment-là, elles deviennent
plus drôles ou plus émotionnelles et vous
voulez donc pouvoir même  même si vous passez
par un précédent pour pouvoir être
suffisamment flexible pour changer quelque chose
Renea April et cet autre gars